hable I am Aiden from California I'm a
musician a songwriter and I really would
like to know what makes music so human
and powerful in its nature thank you
why didn't as you know I know everything
I don't know why but it sure is deep
within us now I remember when I was in
school people in psychology class talked
about dogs
responding to octaves that is the
doubling of the frequency and so there
may be something to that that there are
natural resonances that appeal to us
that has something to do with our voices
but I have also I mean I'm not an expert
on this but I've been to China and
people will listen to sort of western
disco music but other music like swing
music the dud that doesn't appeal to
them that they don't like it there's
something about the traditions that with
tonal language speakers versus us that
doesn't jive doesn't fit in but then in
Japan it's not a tonal language but they
also got something that sounds more like
Chinese to me I don't know it is deep
within us and I will say if you want to
get to Carnegie Hall practice practice
practice I will say scales are very
important do scales that's what it's all
based on somewhere bent down there and
if you're gonna play the blues I'm
looking at you with your guitar if
you're gonna play the blues you got to
get a couple minor chords in there you
gotta have a major third and a seventh
or something like that but I'm not sure
why but it's got to be just ultimately
based on trying to attract a mate that's
got to be what's down in there carry on
it
you